what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are about two or three weeks
out to the release of Black Panther and
I am exceedingly excited for this film's
truth be tell like if I want to be
honest with you guys I'm more excited
for Black Panther that I have been for
any film in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so far I'm more excited for
infinity war because you know I mean
it's infinity war but like you know for
all the movies we've seen so far like
the anticipation I felt I'm the most
excited for Black Panther because it's
the first time like in any fashion that
we get to see his character on the
silver screen and the cast is nothing
short of spectacular which of course
brings us into Eric hill monger being
played by Michael B Jordan and it's
really really exciting because Michael B
Jordan is a fantastic actor I mean it's
just it's crazy to look at the the shows
of the movies that he's been in the wire
house Chronicle but I mean he's I'm
really looking forward to seeing what he
can do in this film because I think
he'll be a great Eric hill monger the
way he's being done which brings us into
this discussion so Eric Hill monger
originally appeared in Marvel Comics in
jungle action issue number six back in
1973 and he was created by Don McGregor
but here's the funny thing Eric hill
mongers origin and really the nature of
his character falls hand-in-hand with
the history of black panther and that's
one of the things we talked about of the
black panther video really Eric hill
monger is kind of like the most notable
villain of black panther maybe outside
of the Alessi's claw i would certainly
say that Eric hill mongers more
important than ulysses clock other
reason for this is because while black
panther did appear back in 1966 and a
couple of fantastic four stories that
was more like an introduction kind of
thing then we talked about that before
that if Marvel wanted to introduce a new
character or a new team they'd throw
them in the Fantastic Four and the way
that original story played out it was
simply just that ulysses klaw had
invaded what conduct somewhere along the
line which led to the death of T'Challa
father allowing T'Challa to take up the
mantle of of Black Panther and what he
ended up doing was basically having the
Fantastic Four traveled to Wakanda and
then facing off against each member of
the team individually for no other
reason than to hone his skills to test
his abilities and to see whether or not
he could successfully face off against
Ulysses Klaw
now of course once the rift was mended
and all that kind of good stuff and you
know to charla basically explained what
was going on for the most part he became
an ally of the Fantastic Four and the
larger superhero community as a whole
and so going between 1966 running up
until about 1973 black panther really
just kind of appeared in other people's
stories which was actually the smarter
way to play this instead of just giving
him his own solo series right off the
bat Marvel was just kind of toying
around
omitting well let's see how he does an
Ironman let's see how he does as part of
the Avengers for a little while now the
time 1973 came around it was really kind
of ripe for black panther to have his
own publication his own solo series and
so in jungle action issue number six not
only was the series kind of relaunched
for his character but it also introduced
Eric hill monger now the reason why I
make the case that Eric hill monger is
so important is because of the fact that
what Kondo is really given to us as this
technologically advanced society the
whole idea of Don McGregor and one of
the reasons why he's hailed as such an
iconic writer is because unlike a lot of
superhero stories at the time instead of
focusing on just the superhero element
superheroes fighting bad guys as
superheroes doing good things
Don McGregor focused more on character
development making the characters
tangible realistic and relatable but the
whole idea here was that Eric hill
monger was established as having been
someone who had basically returned to
Wakanda and the reason why was because
of the fact that when ulysses klaw
hadn't initially invaded Wakanda that he
basically pressed gained multiple people
into joining his crew one of which was
the father of Eric hill monger now in
the battle against T'Challa Eric hill
mongers father was killed but because of
the fact that de chollet was more or
less kind of a harsh King at that point
in time no quarter was given to those
individuals that were viewed to be
traitors and so where the father of Eric
hill monger died Eric and his family
were banished from Wakanda they were
basically exiled and this led to Eric
hill monger taking up residence in
Harlem New York and now again because of
the fact that this is kind of working on
the idea that black panther is more than
just a king from some small fictional
territory in africa because of the fact
that you know black pants are supposed
to be one of the smartest people in the
world
Don McGregor built on this concept and
basically brought and kill monger is a
guy who had studied at MIT he had pushed
his body to the physical limits
basically testing himself so that when
he returned to Wakanda it was really
more or less a ruse he had simply shown
up on the doorstep of black panther and
said look my father brought shame to my
family I want to find a way to make up
for his sins I want to find a way to
basically restore the honor of my family
and the eyes of you as king and so
ultimately to Chara allowed him back and
so what Eric hill monger did is
immediately start going in the process
of trying to form a coup d'etat and so
between jungle action issues a six
through eight which saw the return of
Eric hill monger and his origin being
told with issue seven to around 14 or so
what we got was this kind of tour of
Wakanda in the sense that Black Panther
had faced off against Eric hill monitor
and
kill monger had bested and he'd actually
defeated black panther and so as a
result he basically thrown his body down
into a ravine and then black panther
sort of coming across all these
different individuals that Eric hill
monger had rallied to his cause so
people like venom not the spider-man
venom but just a different guy named
venom you know some of these characters
basically helped Black Panther to offer
a little bit of wisdom where they could
a little bit of guidance remember Black
Panther is basically the best fighter in
all of Wakanda that's really what it's
designed to be he's the smartest person
and the best fighter and so there wasn't
really a whole lot in terms of fighting
skills that they could impart on him but
whatever a little bit he gained helped
just because of the fact that Eric Hill
monger in a lot of ways was equal to
judge Halle himself and so this
eventually segwayed into the conclusion
of the whole jungle action line with
issues 15 16 17 and 18 which basically
saw two Charla overpowering he'll monger
and then effectively killing him now
this is a very very important time for
the Black Panther landscape for a couple
of different reasons
the first was because under the writing
of Don McGregor this jungle action line
was designed to focus almost entirely on
the characters but also build Wakanda
build on the characters who were in it
basically explained to the reader what
goes on there what takes place inside of
all the stuff because remember with the
exception of the first appearance of
black panther in the Fantastic Four
there wasn't really a whole lot given
about what conduct we knew about its
nature we knew it was advanced but
because of the fact that a lot of the
stories of Black Panther appeared and
saw him leaving Wakanda for a time we
didn't really learn a whole lot about
the fictional nation of Wakanda and so
if we learned all kinds of things you
know under the writing of Don McGregor
which was pretty significant I mean the
dorm of OJ different things like that I
mean it was pretty interesting to learn
all that stuff or at least you know see
it brought back now following this the
reason why the jungle action line of
stories really six to two you know 17 or
18 are so significant is because by and
large this story is basically called
Panthers rage and it's considered to be
the first graphic novel of Marvel Comics
now for the most part in in comic books
those guys who were new in comic books
you have a lot of different writing
writing styles or at least publishing
formats that are out there you have
single issues which are exactly what
they sound like
you walk into a comic book store you say
let me get issue number 33 of Black
Panther and they give you that single
issue you have trade paperbacks which
usually are composed of story arcs from
there you go into things like original
graphic novels which are basically
one-off stories just stand-alones
like The Killing Joke is a really good
example and then you have like graphic
novels themselves which in a lot of ways
are trade paperbacks now
me the fundamental difference between a
trade paperback in a graphic novel is
that we're a trade paperback we'll be
one story arc that's part of a larger
ongoing story a graphic novel is the
ongoing story it's the whole thing it's
the whole kit and kaboodle that's why
with regards to Panthers rage it is a
totally cohesive story and the reason
why is because following the conclusion
of Panthers rage and essentially the
death of Erik kill monger we didn't hear
from him for a little while instead a
lot of the emphasis was put on black
panther now truth to tell jungle action
came to an end because the sales were
low and a lot of that was because of the
fact that by the time you got into the
late 1970s Kamara readers had really
just kind of picked out which characters
were their absolute favorites and so for
the most part there wasn't a lot of room
for black panther to grow because there
wasn't really a whole lot of interest in
a fictional nation of Wakanda in
comparison to everything else now for
Erik he'll monger himself he had a
couple of appearances but there were all
he ever really liked to Aventa took
place you know I mean like the maxi
series over the edge which ran for about
ten issues in issue number six his
followers resurrected him but then
ultimately you know he just he was
really defeated and that was about it
when it came to things like Ironman
annual number five you know he was
resurrected by the Mandarin and then
ultimately defeated and returned to a
pile of bones and so there wasn't really
much going on now a lot of that was
Marvel trying to find a way to see if it
was possible to reinvigorate interest in
his character but the whole basis behind
this is that this runs up until 1998 now
the reason for this is because not only
were Marvel characters outside of black
panther already established by the time
the mid 90s came around Marvel was
basically looking around and saying okay
look we have this huge surge of
comic-book interests we're going to
start printing you know multiple covers
and things like that but we're for the
most part gonna keep it isolated to the
most popular superheroes because that's
all anybody really wants to buy not only
that by the time the mid 90s happened
and the comic bust took place Marvel was
still for the most part in the same boat
Marvel looked around and they said okay
so sales are basically at an all-time
low
we can't afford to publish anything
outside of the most popular superheroes
so again that created another quagmire
for the character of life Panther now by
the time the late 90s came around Marvel
was experiencing kind of a resurgence in
font on the financial side in the sense
that you had like Ike Perlmutter and avi
arad and all these guys who had come on
board through toy biz and they were
basically bankrolling Marvel to keep
them afloat and all that would go into
the formation of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe under Kevin Feige but in terms
of the comic-book side you had a couple
of writers Joe Quesada and Jimmy Paul
Muni and
had launched a kind of a publishing
house called event comics and what
Marvel did is they kind of looked around
and they said okay look it's pretty
pricey to pay your average writer you
know and your average artists a market
share in order to publish these
superheroes and so what they did is it's
the less popular superheroes daredevil
Black Panther Punisher and they handed
them over to event publications and
Jimmy pommy ah tea and and Joe Quesada
had those characters written and drawn
in-house and what that did is it allowed
Marvel to launch a publication called
Marvel nights and so what Marvel Knights
did is it basically said here's all
these characters that normally wouldn't
sell on their own you'll still get their
books but while they're released by
Marvel they're basically written and
drawn by event publishing and so in this
era of the Marvel Knights line
christopher priest came on to write
Black Panther now Christopher priest's
writing of the black panther line of
comics was landmark and it was huge
because for the most part it was the
first real time that we started to see -
Chavez character expanded and grown in a
variety of ways again it was designed to
kind of return the story to its roots
and for priests the Black Panther comics
as he saw them the way that he wrote
them was the most logical follow-up to
basically what had happened in the
original jungle action that were jungle
action and the stories have followed it
in terms of life Panther solo series his
appearance and Avengers and various
other things while it had established
that vibranium was the most valuable
material in the world that a dime-sized
amount of vibranium would sell for
twenty thousand dollars that there would
be a lot of people who would be vying
for it and so what ended up happening is
that when Chris were priests took over
the title one of the first things he did
is he looked around the entire history
of the Marvel landscape in relation to G
Charla and tried to find a way to make
it work
and so what he did is he introduced a
character named Everett Ross and the
reason for this was because one of the
things that fans did enjoy about black
panther was him being part of the
Avengers because he was able to bring a
kind of perception to the team that not
everybody was familiar with this
combined with the fact that he joined
the Avengers explicitly to keep an eye
on them to basically monitor monitor the
team and determine whether or not they
would be a credible threat to Uwe
- what Conda established the idea that
in the eyes of like Panther it was
Wakanda first and then everything else
second and so with that in mind Everett
Ross served as a kind of liaison for
Black Panther in the United States and
so the way these stories would play out
would be in a traditional superhero
fashion that you would have black
panther who would show up in the United
States by way of Everett Ross and then
he would say well on me I have to go
check on something and then he would go
do superhero stuff whether he teamed up
with daredevil or whether he went to go
join the Avengers on some
whatever the case may be that would
really be about it but the other half of
this was to basically maintain the
political elements and so with regards
to the larger Black Panthers story one
of the things that Christopher priests
established was that because Wakanda was
home to vibranium there were a lot of
people who were vying for it and so what
you had in my condo was a guy named
wherever into key B and Reverend a cave
he was a guy who was basically backed by
a lot of these foreign intelligence
agencies it was very similar to like the
soviet-afghan war in the 1970s in the
sense that you had the Soviet backed
Afghan government and then you had the
u.s. backed mujahideen it was very much
that way when it came to the black
panther line of stories that you
basically had all these different
clandestine organizations that were
vying for a piece of vibranium and that
Reverend icky beat was the means by
which they could achieve it because what
a kid he did is he basically launched a
coup d'etat with in Wakanda itself while
black panther was gone and the hope was
that akivi would basically come to power
and rule as more of a religious figure
as opposed to anything else and then in
turn start siphoning off pieces of
vibranium to those who are willing to
pay enough for you know whereas Black
Panther would simply say no I'm only
going to give it to people that I think
deserve it and so because of this when
Black Panther returned really between
issues I would say between issues 13
running all the way up to like 25 it was
basically this massive grandiose story
that dealt with like Eric Hill monger
returning defeating T'Challa and then
effectively taking his place now as far
as this ideology of Eric Hill monger
actually replacing T'Challa as king of
Wakanda it could not have lasted forever
and so because of this what Christopher
priest did is in issues 19 through 25 he
basically had Eric hill monger take the
next step now for those of you guys who
are not familiar with how the Black
Panther concept works a person can't
just become Black Panther like you
couldn't storm Wakanda and then
eliminate the existing Black Panther put
on the Panther suit and say I am now
black panther it's as much a religious
ideology as it is a political ideology
and so what Chris rope Reese did is that
in these issues in 19 through 25 in this
six issue story arc he essentially had
Eric hill monger consumed the
heart-shaped herb and so when a person
is vying to become like Panther you have
to defeat the sitting Black Panther you
have to defeat his six best warriors all
at the same time and then assuming that
you managed to pull that off you in turn
have to consume the heart-shaped herb
now in truth the heart-shaped herb for
years was believed to be this kind of
herb that was given to the wakandans by
the gods and it was basically a ritual
it was a test of sorts and truth the
heart-shaped herb is just an herb that's
with radiation from vibranium and so if
a person consumes it in their body can't
physically handle it it'll kill them off
but it's kind of a religious / practical
way to differentiate the weak from the
strong and so if a person isn't strong
enough they'll effectively die from it
now there is kind of a religious
Connaughton to it in the sense that by
all standards of measurement Eric hill
monger was equal to Black Panther in
terms of strength speed all that kind of
stuff even when Panther had his powers
and so the result was that when Eric
Hill Munger consumed the heart-shaped
herb he basically fell into a coma and
this was a way for his priests to remove
Eric hill monger as the sitting King and
in turn bring back to chala as the
actual king himself now because of the
fact that you know Chris were priests
run only lasted for about 62 issues
winded up happening is that in the last
couple issues or so really issue number
Christopher priests intended to bring
back Eric hill monger and continue the
story the problem with this and as far
as I'm aware Christopher priests
effectively quit Marvel around 2003 2004
2005 somewhere around there and
basically walked away and so the Black
Panther vol 3 line ran until really
about 2003 after which Christopher
priest left now the reasons for his
motivation and leaving are really kind
of speculative I mean I don't have a
definitive answer but as far as I've
been able to tell a lot of it was just a
refusal of Marvel to recognize his
contributions because one thing to bear
in mind
Christopher priest was the first
african-american writer to actually
receive a full-time writing gig for
either Marvel or DC it was the first
time he'd broken that barrier but Marvel
has a history of engaging in that action
of just refusing to give people credit
that's the reason why Jack Kirby left in
like the late 1960s early 1970s and went
to DC now in DC he was just kind of
screwed over and ultimately left and
came back to Marvel but that's one of
the things that's happened before but
again a lot of this is speculation just
from various articles that I've read
from vulture and you know different
things like that because I don't have a
definitive answer to that question it's
just kind of speculation but regardless
of the motivations behind Christopher
priests leading the fact remains but his
intention was to basically kind of
transform the black panther series and
then used that as a springboard platform
to launch something else and so in 2003
Christopher priest launched a line of
publications or at least a story called
the crew and I was actually cancelled
after like seven issues I think but the
whole idea behind this was that Eric
hill monger had basically reached out to
a guy named Casper Cole who'd already
been already become the new black
panther and the idea was that Casper
Cole would be transformed into the white
tiger of
of the Panther cult and in turn would go
on to become his own superhero but again
because of the fact that Chris release
effectively walked away from Marvel a
lot of these themes were just kind of
left hanging they were just sort of left
there and they were open and there
really wasn't a whole lot to do with him
and so in 2008 under the Riding of
Reginald Hudlin in issues 35 through 38
of Black Panther vol 4 Eric Hill monger
was effectively killed off in the sense
that he basically become this kind of
despots
this ruler of a place called maganda and
try to kind of fashion his own Wakanda
of sorts the issue with this is that it
ran into direct conflict with Black
Panther when Eric hill monger had
kidnapped Monica Rambeau
who was actually kind of like the second
Captain Marvel but she's really best
known as spectrum meaning that she's
just like she's a perfect wavelength of
energy is really all it is but because
of the fact that Eric hill monger had
kidnapped Monica Rambeau this brought
Black Panther directly into conflict
with him to basically end Eric hill
monger once and for all and so basically
what ended up happening was kind of this
male drawn-out fight that took place
over the course of about four issues and
then ultimately you had Eric hill monger
who is finally killed by Monica Rambeau
and that was basically the end of him as
far as I'm aware he's never been seen or
heard from since now in truth he may
return and I kinda hope he does just
because of the fact that Eric hill
monger you know historically speaking it
doesn't really have any powers he
doesn't really have any abilities he's
not like Black Panther where he consumed
the heart-shape herb and he gained you
know all this enhanced strength speed
and the Jillian all that kind of stuff
he's just a guy that pushed his body to
the physical limits so he could be equal
to Black Panther which is actually
pretty impressive but having been one of
the smartest villains to exist in the
sense that he's wildly educated having
gone to like the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology because of the fact that
he's so intelligent when it comes to
like military tactics different things
like that because he was the first
villain of Black Panther to really
elevate to Charla from being just a
super hero to being someone that has to
deal with various insurgencies inside of
his own Kingdom and helped to kind of
develop that aspect of his line of
storytelling I would really love to see
Eric hill monger come back but even if
he doesn't return a comic book form the
fact that we're gonna see him in the
movie is a pretty big deal because I
think what you guys are gonna see what
Eric hill monger assuming that he's done
right and that he's not going to be like
a lot of the other villains that we've
seen in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
he's not gonna be like Obadiah Stane
from Iron Man 1 where he's just a guy
that's trying to take over Iron Man's
company you know he's not gonna be like
Red Skull where he's looking for a
cosmic cube I think that what you guys
are going to see in Eric hill monger is
he's going to be exceedingly intelligent
he's gonna be one of the most brilliant
villains
that we've seen I think he's gonna do a
lot of things that are gonna take a lot
of people by surprise and really helped
it kind of like elevate this idea the
Black Panther is a lot more than just a
superhero that has Panther powers I
think it's really going to elevate and
establish the idea that Black Panther
and the various foes he faces are some
of the smartest people out there in the
entirety of the Marvel Universe but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come this explain make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the robb cork if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]